there's a quote you have that that I saw
that I thought is really fascinating
which is you I think I'm getting this
right but you said you feel like you're
a character actor that's trapped in a
leading lady's body and I thought that's
so true because and I'm you're stunning
you're stunningly attracted no seriously
I'm yeah you are beautiful yeah and this
is we're not being nice we're sort
of just like stunned uh and I feel that
way every time I run into you
um and you've but you've got you know
it's it's crazy to act like it's a
contradiction at all but your comedy
chops are so crazy good that to to have
both and then also to have all these
other Ambitions that you have I think is
uh very uh maybe it's it's unusual
you know it it didn't used to be that's
I I think about like the old movies
stars of you know the Greta garbos and
like the May West like they were so cute
and like even like Katherine Hepburn and
Audrey Hepburn they they got to yes they
were like leading ladies I mean Audrey
happened probably more than the rest of
that list but there were like you know
Joan Crawford was like abroad you know
like she really got Rosalind Russell
like Auntie memes like my favorite thing
growing up like I was like I just want
to be Auntie Mame and that that's what's
always appealed to me you know the um
just people who really got to chew up
the scenery and like do physical comedy
as well as I don't know everything and
then there became like these ingenues
who were just like damsels in distress
and I've played a lot of those my like
girlfriends the girl you know there's
not much to do just kind of like
be in the movie with the guy like you
know when I saw you in 40 year old
virgin obviously you were
um you know crazy attractive popping on
the screen but also the way you were
playing it was so funny in a different
way that I hadn't quite seen before to
know and I remember thinking she's so
funny in this way I haven't seen anyone
else quite do this because a character
that was just kind of there but then it
just became like a really funny
character because yeah you did so much
fun doing that yeah Beth
with the I think a little thongs
not that I remember yeah you really
remember that yeah I was escorted out of
that movie four times
um you kept coming back in yeah I kept
coming in and saying it's my right
I have not seen that movie in a long
time but you know it did was my friend's
kid who's 13.
wow
like so uh he had a bar mitzvah and then
he watched the four-year-old virgin and
I was like I'm like literally his like
Auntie and now he'd like to speak with
you if possible I was like what were you
thinking he's like I kind of forgot
about that
like really uh also you've done you you
have I mean in the comedy where like
people like Paul Rudd you've really
clicked you really click with him yeah
I've worked with Paul like six times or
something now maybe like four or five a
bunch a lot
yeah I mean he never calls me
well that's Rudd it's just how it is
just busy being expensive man
don't be little he's he's belittled he
is he really is that's the whole point
his whole power is that he is belittled
you're right you're right how dare you
belittle Ant-Man
yeah
Paul wherever you are we're sorry it
feels to me like in your career I mean I
loved you on
30 Rock and I think that was supposed to
be just
I mean it wasn't planned to be a
recurring role no and then uh you came
on as uh Jack Donahue's lady at love
interest and how quickly did you know oh
this is going this is going places well
I went in for I had two episodes I think
was a initial like offer like come on do
a little quick thing two episodes I was
playing you know this news this Fox News
type cast newscaster and um and then
like a month or so later it was like hey
did you did you like doing that you want
to come back and do this stuff sure and
then it was like three years later and
suddenly I was pregnant with this baby
and we were getting married
that's nice so it's pretty nice and and
uh I really enjoyed working on that show
loved it and uh uh and then of course
Pitch Perfect is where it felt like
things really ramp up in in a great way
because you get to you get more control
you get to move yeah closer into a
different role well we my so my husband
and I who have a company together
Brownstone Productions we produced Pitch
Perfect all three of those and I
directed the second one and you know it
was my first foray into doing yeah make
making more of my Hollywood life I guess
and just acting and
hanging out by the phone waiting for
somebody to call but you know it's it's
occurring to me now I'm remembering that
Lucille Ball if you see uh photos of her
in the 1940s
stunning I mean like like you a a
leading lady yeah who then uh you know
but definitely a character like she's
someone that that's who I should have
named when I was naming them right but
you know what can we edit that no we we
can't afford that make sure there's no
money for that I didn't mean to say
Audrey Hepburn Audrey Hepburn
I meant to say that someone went after
Audrey Hepburn I wanted to say loose
sail balls but you know if you see you
know people think of her as Lucy and and
the the you know and and and you see
pictures of her uh in the in the 40s and
she just drop dead yeah supermodel
gorgeous uh and then to have those kind
of Comedy chops but then she and her
husband take over uh they figure out a
way to own the factory and I think they
have the largest deal at CBS like that
had ever happened at that point yeah at
some point I think like now Ryan Murphy
has one of those or Shonda Rhimes hasn't
been bigger one right like and the day
that would have been Lucy and Desi's
yeah but also they I don't think it had
been done before no I don't think
anybody had done that I mean taking
control you know of the whole thing yeah
and I think that there used to be just a
different attitude I mean obviously in
the 20s and 30s and 40s like shut up and
act don't worry you're pretty little
head about it we'll take care of this
and so and suddenly they were like no no
you can't do any of it without us we own
the whole thing it was amazing they're
they were incredible they were
incredible business too yeah some things
just truly strive for yeah